I'm glad we're in starts with that I
thought we had to win to get in so I
mean Bob just told me that walking in so
but that's cool but doesn't make me feel
better I know
Kal Shannon after Sunday's game
congratulations during the playoffs like
they weren't going to be condolences
lost at home to the Atlanta Falcons
skater guy wasn't happy right there he
wasn't happy and I'm not good Ollie's
and turns and flips with a skateboard
yesterday we thought that they would win
we thought that they would not have that
and that the tread that because he said
Friday right it's very easy to get his
players to understand this is a trap
game because all he has to do is show
them what they did to the Saints in the
same building where the 49ers barely
escaped with a win
the Falcons went in there and kicked the
crap out of the Saints that's all you
need to show yeah but you look they're
tired they haven't had their buy in
weeks it was week four they really need
a playoff buy and they beat up football
team right if they have to play wildcard
weekend at Dallas or at Philly that may
not be good for the 49 well I mean it's
been a long stretch and they certainly
have played a lot of physical football
games and what was it yesterday five
defensive starters weren't playing for
them is that right I mean it was
somewhere in that range but they've
overcome that all I know they out I know
I I'm just speaking to a bigger point of
just like you said they're kind of worn
out and it's the NFL and you know
sometimes I think it's football fans and
me included we think it's like oh here's
the number-one team in football and
here's the number 24 team in football
they should just run them over this is
like college football right no it's not
like college football it's the NFL and
on a given Sunday when you got awesome
players like that Ryan and Julio Jones
on your team and a motivated head coach
like Dan Quinn and then yes you catch a
team like the 49ers coming off one of
the hardest three-game stretches in the
history of the NFL as far as the team's
record they're playing you know one
little letdown and all of a sudden you
look up and you go holy cow weren't a
tight football game here against a team
that we're clearly better than and Matt
Ryan and company took control of it and
yeah Kyle I don't think I had a great
day they didn't they weren't dominant on
the offensive side of the ball and I
just think everything kind of caught up
to them that way yeah and you know the
fact that the Falcons can win in Santa
Clara yeah in New Orleans yeah but they
otherwise are 3 and 9 it's kind of crazy
you know you see
the outcome yesterday nice a maybe that
saves Dan Quinn's job but then you look
at everything else they did this year
and it's like how can we justify
continuing with Dan Quinn and Arthur
Blank I I think still has a decision to
make because the salary cap is gonna
force them to hang on to some guys that
maybe a new coach would want to get rid
of and maybe it makes that job a little
less attractive because you're not gonna
have the roster flexibility and you are
gonna have the cap issues but I look I
think the Falcons would love to get a
reset would love to get a do-over next
year at 0 and 0 with an opportunity to
start from scratch because I think the
tone of your season really does get set
those first few weeks when you get some
wins early the confidence builds like it
did for the 49ers and the next thing you
know you're in a special season and I
think that could happen for the Falcons
too can happen for a lot of teams you're
right the NFL the best teams the good
teams are kind of packed tight together
and it's your schedule yeah out of the
gates do you have a bunch of tough games
do the Vikings had to go to menace I
mean that the Falcons that go to
Minnesota and face the Vikings right out
of the gate yeah that's a little more
difficult than the draw that some of
these other teams have gotten so you do
see how how narrow the gap is and the
talent in the NFL on a weekend like
yesterday and specifically a game like
yesterday between the Falcons of the 40
yeah you definitely do and you're right
I mean a season can be built on early
season schedule and then the team's
ability to stay healthy and those were
issues for the the Atlanta Falcons
health has been an issue really the last
two years for their football team but
banged up on the offensive line early on
and they weren't playing that good there
had some defensive injuries that hurt
them so they had a deal with that and
they just didn't weather the storm that
well through that early to early mid
season part of the schedule and it fell
apart on them but yesterday I mean again
I got to give Dan Quinn a lot of credit
you know ken John bartered fumbles a
punt in return we just showed the
highlight of it the 49ers scored
touchdown they go up 19 to 10 19 to 10
in the third quarter I know I was
sitting there going okay here we go
49ers a put em away now it's over and I
just think it's a tribute to them the
Falcons I say and they go down they
answer the bells nine play 75-yard Drive
touchdown 1917
you know the Niners
answer back with a field goal and Matt
Ryan and Julio Jones say up screw it it
doesn't matter we still got a touchdown
wins this game and they drive down and
it's Julio Matt Ryan in the back yard
and they go down and make it happen yeah
we both thought our pick of the 49ers
covering was going to be accurate yeah
and then it all fell apart quickly and
three straight games now for the 49ers
decided on the final play from scrimmage
amazing and hey they lost they lost two
and they won one and still all I have to
do yeah well not that it's easy anyway
that's the thing you're right now the
Rams are gonna come in on Saturday night
very desperate because it's a playoff
game for them but the 49ers know they're
gonna have to go to Seattle yes and
maybe they will maybe they won't have a
feeling it's gonna come down to the last
play yeah well it certainly will be an
exciting game cuz you know Seattle at
home is gonna battle and Russell Wilson
and everything like that but I think you
know you just made the point really you
know three games in a row coming down to
the last play with the 49ers it's just
not easy to answer the bell like that
every week so you know there you are
human you know feelings oh we just beat
the best team in football on the road
maybe the Saints we're feeling good
about ourselves and the Atlanta Falcons
are fighting for their lives right now
and it just shows you that not the
plague the Atlanta Falcons are playing
for nothing right now well Dan Quinn's
fighting for his life that's what I
meant - hi superlatives for week 15
coming up next record
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports